[Music]
people have called you a terrorist
lawyer how do you respond to that
well when i defended someone charged
with rape nobody called me a rapist
when i defended someone charged with
murder nobody dug around my backyard
but when someone's accused of terrorism
people like you seem to think that's
different
you want to represent the head recruiter
for 9 11.
constitution doesn't have an asterisk at
the end that says terms and conditions
apply
they kidnapped me from my home and
brought me here with a bag on my head
and chains around my body
what did they accuse you of three years
they charged me with nothing
rough justice that's what this
administration wants
we are seeking the death penalty what if
you're wrong
what if you built this place you
abandoned all of your
principles all of your laws and you're
wrong
you need to tell me what happened to you
i can't defend you my captors cannot
forgive me for something that i've never
done
maybe he's guilty someone has to answer
for the tower
someone not just anyone
in arabic the word for free and the word
for forgiveness is the same one
i want to forgive
this is how even here i can be fruitful
[Music]
you